tim draper i don't know if you saw the
tim draper interview with gary uh uh
three years ago in 2018 when this
interview took place and draper gave a
system i love what he said and by the
way for people that don't know who tim
draper is tim draper is a beast of a guy
is who he is here's how he broke down
the system he says
bankers are panicking he said this in 18
he says this is their system it's always
been their system step number one they
say this is nothing cryptocurrency
bitcoin nft nothing you ain't got to
worry about it there is no way they can
you know compete with somebody like us
where jamie dimon's got seven trillion
dollars of money circulating through
chase on a daily basis that's like
whatever the number they say that's a
pretty big number that they go through
right so he says step number one
these guys are nothing they're not gonna
make it it's just the fat it's gonna go
away step number two now it's too big
where you have to face it okay so what
they do is three bankers all get
together and say we can't make this
happen what do we do step number four is
we sue them step number five is we bring
our government friends to say i need a
favor i need you to sue those guys and
he's telling this to gary when gary
wasn't yet the sec chair he was only the
chair of the cft uh uh
commodities uh futures uh trade
commission right
he's clairvoyant
exactly that's what was so epic about i
don't know if you've seen this or not
what did gary say powerful so then
gary's trying well well but but but i
think we're already there but i think
we're already there and then he says and
the last one is tim draper freaking mike
drop he says this make or buy this is
what everybody do all the great
companies they either make or buy he
says you either have to choose to make a
similar product similar exchange similar
token similar wallet or you have to buy
it and that's eventually going to happen
so
that's where we are today now go to
politics and bring politics on board
for four years i've been saying when
people say bitcoin ethereum ripple you
know all these crypto patrick that's
what i said you have to realize
there are those who are driven by
freedom leave me alone let me do
something better and there are those
that can't stand it that you keep
getting richer and more powerful they
cannot stand that you keep making money
we had matt zeller on yesterday and we
talked about the trump and i hate trump
i hate trump you know how angry he got
in and you and i had lunch at louis
bossie i like matt zeller yeah oh i do
too yeah we're bringing him back on
board i think matt's great yeah but uh
uh you and i talked about it during
lunch and you said what he said why do
you think it's such a thing about he
broke him yeah what was it there's
something about trump that makes these
people and i said i silently angry i
said because
there are certain people in life you're
okay losing to you're kind of like well
listen i lost my cousin
the guy kind of comes from the richest
family and he went to harvard i'm okay
if i lose to that guy makes more money
than he's more successful it's fine
but then you have that one cousin whose
mom and dad were let's just say you know
divorce and one was an alcoholic one
went to jail
that cousin beats your ass in life you
can't deal with that you got to diminish
him you got to throw him you got to do
all this other stuff right
krypto is almost like that cousin in
that coin where it's like listen fiat's
been around for a while gold's been
around for a while who the hell you
think
you are
there are a lot of people that don't
want to see this happening but there's
one good thing that's happening today to
the crypto community
there's more true believers today than
ever before
there are more credible sources that are
coming and saying look we're putting our
money into it we're going to fight as
well it's now the crypto community is a
political party yep so we're back in the
days where democrats wanted to win the
black vote and they did after burying
goldwater that's a great point and when
they
the democrats wanted to win the black
vote because blacks forever have been
conservatives i mean martin luther king
was a conservative he was a republican
we got to win it barry goldwater gave it
away went from 60 percent to 92
african-americans voted for who for
democrats and they've had it since then
92 80 civil rights it's been a while
right yep
political parties today have to be very
careful and i think this is going to
favor whoever is on the free enterprise
side of the political side because
gary's a democrat
biden's a democrat kamala is a democrat
and the ones that are going after crypto
are all on one side of the political
party
the libertarians the independents which
is the crypto community crypto
committee's not republicans they're
typically independents and libertarians
anti-establishment anti-establishment
which republican is establishment to
them so is the democratic party
but i think what's happening right now
is if if this happens
i don't think this is just a financial
issue for them if they settle the you
know what whatever they do forget about
that part i think they're going to be
crushed politically because it's no
longer just 100 000 votes or half a
million votes you've got millions on top
of millions that now have influence i'll
tell you why you're 100 right especially
the younger community all right this is
again eb tucker great great guy we had
on last week
you know there's kids that i've coached
in baseball kids that that i still
follow that are now young adults they've
never held gold they don't give a
about gold but they've been trading
crypto for five years absolutely they've
gone and they they're they're learning
blockchain technology in schools i
learned cursive like you know what i'm
saying these kids are learning
blockchain triple ledger they understand
the technology in ways that we don't you
know we're almost old in this and these
guys this is this is not like new alien
technology to the next generation this
is just a way of life to the next
generation so it's only going to get
bigger and they saw what government does
they saw with with gme what happened
with gme when the government literally
stepped in and made it okay for the
hedge fund not to go under for people
that don't remember what happened with
gme they overhedged on a short wall
street bets came out a couple and you
know rogue analysts came out and said
you know these guys are leveraged past
their teeth all you got to do is keep
the keep the price above the put and
they got to pay whatever it could go up
to a million a share theoretically and
it had gotten up it was a six dollar
share it had gotten up over 350 dollars
and it was going to go up over a
thousand and they just turned it off you
could sell the stock right but you
couldn't buy it no you're right right so
the
what the sec did in that regard or what
they didn't do i think i ended up
getting like a class action like 12
check from robin hood or something like
that we built all these exchanges
if you didn't believe
in the net in the necessity for a
decentralized unregulated blockchain
like yeah you can lose your money on
mount gox but you can also lose your
money in the stock market and they could
steal from you and they'll you have no
recourse whatsoever
that right there
that what happened with that wall street
bets what happened with that 6 million
you know i think it's up to 10 million
reddit uh
a subreddit
is you had an entire block worldwide
that lost trust and faith in the market
and in regulation whatever little faith
that they had in regulation they lost it
all overnight let me tell you how on
point you are just a little over a month
ago i i started a website and i'm
plugging it but i don't make any money
there's no sponsors it's called
cryptolaw.us
and i i put an app in it and all you do
is you put in your address and your zip
code and you type your message and it
goes to your congress office
and your two senators
in a little over a month
messages
have been sent to
these elected officials 100 senators
have been contacted by these crypto
people
and 420 representatives all right it's
making a difference they are very
engaged all right that's an incredible
number that happens six thousand but
that doesn't do anything trust me when i
tell you haven't been in government that
does everything so many people don't
make contact with their elected
officials that the few people that do
their voices amplified so much i tell i
tell a story from when i i think one of
the first times i was on the podcast it
was an old lady and none and she thought
people were speeding too fast down the
church and she would literally call and
show up at the state house once a week
hey we need a speed we need a speed bump
is is there any way we can get a speed
bump i'll raise money for a speed bump
and then finally it got to a point where
it was like we need to fast track the
speed bump i don't want to deal with
this lady anymore she was the nicest
activist in history the lady got her
speed bump it took her like four months
right it was just one person
that writing an email making a phone
call showing up the state house and she
got her speed bump yeah you know like it
and the system works if you're the
squeaky wheel gets the oil and that
cryptolaw.com that's a game changer and
i'm actually wrong it's 8 000. i just
remember it's over 8 000 messages have
been sent to them and
people are sending me some of their
letters and some of them many of them
get the form letter hey thank you for
contact don't do that don't do the
formula right some have been doing that
i'm talking about
the sec i'm not the sec the elected
representatives they're getting
from the app but some of them are
actually meeting with their constituents
and learning because they see where this
is going i've had people send me letters
that they received from their
congressmen a couple of them here in
florida where they said we're gonna uh
we're we're involved in this sec we're
monitoring a thousand people bro eight
thousand people look at jersey you just
had phil murphy win by what six thousand
votes yeah you think that he's thinking
guys listen eight thousand people he's
like if they're gonna write me an email
they're going to vote let me tell you
let me tell you if i'm if i'm liber if
i'm the democratic party right no the
republican party
or if i've ever like the rem
libertarian party that puts a candidate
like george jorgensen love her
philosophies
i love the philosophies you can't sell
you're not a salesperson right people
thought spike cohen was running if they
if there ever was a time that you
saw an opportunity for ross pearl was
able to get to 21 whatever whatever the
number was 19 to 21
as an independent
if you've ever wanted to capitalize on a
public if today libertarian independent
party wanted to get to 30 35
like this is a market this is not going
away so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]